[Music]
okay guys I read this Twitter thread
that shut up it was pretty funny what it
is say dish girl alright so this girl
her name is and bara she tweeted out and
Mauro
sorry it's cuz I didn't it oh my god no
no I did absolutely yes you just went to
college with nothing happened no I swear
yeah sure lying so she tweeted out as a
public service and do stressful times
I'd like to offer as a palate cleanser
the most embarrassing moment of my life
are you guys ready for the story yes
maybe he can tell us is he with the
college with her he did it was an
embarrassing moment to hear to hear her
name a year I trusted you yeah
again so she says tennis years ago my
ex-boyfriend and I visited a spa in
Germany it's swimsuits in the pool but
you have to be naked in the sauna oh I
read this you're [ __ ] cute by the way
I speak no German okay lobster yes we'll
get there hold daddy okay so boyfriend
and I agreed to meet in the cafe I get
undressed grab a little towel and go off
to the sauna there are two unmoor
unmarked doors at the end of a corridor
I take a guess and I go through the one
on the left it's not the door to the
sauna it's the fire escape the door is
locked the door locks behind me I am
trapped inside the fire escape in the
NIP it's two stories dark grim noisy
because of huge fans I bang on the fire
escape door until I actually hurt myself
nothing yell for help nothing holy
crying I run downstairs trying to work
out which part of me I should cover with
the little towel my face a single
buttock
oh she's butt naked with just a little
towel with just a little bang on the
second second-floor doors for 10 minutes
and yell some more nothing on the ground
floor there's an unlocked door jackpot
but no it's a terrifying machine room
with massive fans and pumps and
electrocution symbols on everything
friends there's nothing quite like
running naked and crying around an
industrial machine room I spot a service
lift
sheer panic I run into the lift covering
each boob in turn mashing the buttons I
go up and down in the left a few times
there's a security camera in the lift i
torn between I don't want anyone to see
this and I really really want someone to
see this and rescue me I move the little
towel between strategic areas while
sobbing and waving at the camera after a
few rides up and down there's a German
loudspeaker announcement and I just know
it's about me like the naked girl in the
fire-escape lift please stop bashing
buttons or whatever but I can't
understand it so I just growled out cry
louder and gesture at the camera
eventually the lift doors open a spa
employee stands there he is the most
dressed man to ever be wearing clothes
but he has brought no towel for me he
says something in German I cry he sighs
waves for me to follow him I go after
him still switching around this
washcloth apparently the only way out of
the fire escape is to fully leave the
building
so I'm cowering on the edge of the
pavement and hysterical and he points
around the corner and the only way back
in is along the street through reception
where people are totally [ __ ] do you
think it's real I don't know we're
getting to the end I now have an
out-of-body experience a shame a shame
blackout I have reached my max I go
fully through the embarrassment out to
the other side time slows down and can
hear the music of the spheres I stopped
crying dropped the washcloth shoulders
back head high follow him along the
street past people parking their cars
standing in line with their families
people say things point I cannot hear
them i transcend it too with shame
untouchable reception is busy so busy he
has to yell at people to make way so I
can get through the crowd the guy
explains I'm guessing the situation of
the receptionist it takes actual minutes
an old lady gives me her pool floats
it's shaped like a lobster
yeah the claws rest on my boobs
the receptionist asked for my ID I'm
wearing only a lobster where would I be
keeping my [ __ ] ID receptionist sighs
and leads me through the turnstile ten
minutes later when I run sobbing into a
towel I find my boyfriend in the cafe
and he has the audacity to be grumpy
because he's been waiting for an hour
well she had the audacity to kind of
first of all say that if she was a man
this is the matriarchy attacks again if
she was a man she would have to register
as a sex offender just so you know very
true we're having walk
around a bunch of people you see you
stand on that pole on that soapbox you
go boy you fall preach we have no way
man out there I'm not sure of which door
to go through and I'm gonna go fully
through this door without looking first
into the outside I think this was a
creative writing type of exercise
because yeah if you didn't know the
words like and immediately you see it's
like outdoors not sauna feeling like
naked to tell you walk into rooms a lot
like you know looking like the stairway
in a hotel like when you go to that
stairway like you know like this is a
stairway okay this probably isn't even
it like if the Sun is on this floor I'm
open the door to like the place where
all the Santa's are so why'd you let
that door closed like without checking
fire and I find hard to believe that no
one offered a jacket or anything to
cover like I would take my shirt off off
my back yeah woman right it's not like
she looked like she was having fun
she says she like threw the towel down
and she proudly like when do the crowd
naked it doesn't random lobster
somewhere yes that something straight
out of a sitcom yeah and I got a
playable lobster like who's is there a
pool there like it's on a sample yeah no
one's bringing pool gear yeah that's
what I've never seen that day that plate
of a lobster you couldn't really chill
him gonna play the lobster very easily
cuz they were very spread out I don't
see it and also people are like did the
lobster come home with you and she said
no I had to give it back because I
wouldn't fit through the turn turnstiles
oh so how'd the person why the person
bring it I'm like I think you guys are
bringing up some really great points
mm-hmm but it was a nice story good read
good read fun time I had fun and then
she brought it back in the end with
something that she mentioned in the
beginning with the boyfriend like and
then he was mad at me ah ha ha ha so
funny and that's why you've been in it
what a punchline
yeah so well at least it gives us
something to talk about other than Kobe
have you guys been stuck and make it
somewhere before like this stalk naked I
felt like I got stuck naked when this
one chick surprised me by being naked
and I did not want her to be it was a
pleasant surprise
no oh this is this chick that I was very
lightly dating I was like diet dating
this chick you don't want to be naked
with someone that you're dating so I had
a one-night stand with her and then I
was trying to make a work out because I
felt guilty that I had a one-night stand
to begin with and then she came out like
I came to see her and she came out
completely naked and I was like oh no I
don't like her I don't like this girl
came out naked outside of her front door
no no like in the when I was chilling in
her living the wait was it her body that
time to all it was her it was I just
didn't like her I didn't like so it
doesn't matter that she was naked out
you didn't want to do sexual things to
her cause you don't like her so happy
power to sort of force him to propose to
me that was like you better give me that
dick that's right and then the rest is
history I had her put on clothes I was
like you know did you break up that day
yeah we went to Phil's BBQ in San Diego
very good barbecue humiliated you're a
horrible person I'm just kidding gonna
give her in her a pity fire pull a
band-aid off fast and slowly target is
if I can't emotionally [ __ ] I know that
sounds so lame but it means more when
you are connected emotionally I've never
ever had a one-night stand out of all
the partners up here are you that like
got to know them over their time or we
were already friends are we talking
before I've never ever had a one-night
thing oh wait what do you consider a
one-night stand though because
smashin ever talk to you again hi nice
to meet you smash here's my penis talk
to you okay
that like before the smash does that
matter at all what that's I'm saying
like I'm usually knew them beforehand
not like like they like to classify it
as a 1 is 10 does it matter if like you
talk to someone for some time whatever
and then you have sex and then you never
speak to them again would that be that's
just coasting I think that would just be
ghosts in it so when I say I just like
you you meet somebody in a bar and then
okay wait wait what if you like okay
you're a comic no and then you have a
whole show yeah so specific what counts
as being a one-night stand cuz like you
feel like you know then like you you got
if you know they know me you hung out
with them they'll owe me what they know
me might comment on their the
comecomecome
no two comics all to copy both comic I
don't do comics Yeah right
no I don't I don't wear something that
it's like I know how hard it is from
women to get a leg up in this industry I
don't want to be part of the problem
mmm like guys top just like chicks talk
and so I don't ever want my blood
I don't I don't want they didn't also I
don't want to be because I'm in a
position right now where I can put
people on my stage like if me and
somebody hooked up and I don't put them
on the step oh that makes sense cuz
you're a position of power yeah it's
like I generally just don't think you're
funny are you absolutely don't think
you're ready for generally don't think
you're right for my crown or like hey I
don't think you're hot enough for this
yeah I don't want that to be myself that
makes especially in this climate you
don't want someone to be like I slept
with him and you didn't even put me up I
don't want that so the first time that
you suck my dick he did really good but
then like you were pretty lazy last
night something you're going up tonight
yeah yeah are we wasting them but is
that would you consider that a one-night
stand blog is we're both comics we
hooked up for one night yeah but we
known each other before well like maybe
you did a couple shows together before
yeah it's a one night well
when I stand because you [ __ ] you're
never gonna [ __ ] again never no no no no
if you never [ __ ] again which I already
had a pre-existing relationship that's
not a one-night yeah like you know you
might see each other again like if you
do a show like one night I like that one
night stand is like we have no ways to
contract each other right right like you
don't have my phone number you might not
even have my name we met we hooked up we
have fun
I left in the morning who didn't even
seem you got that someone nightstand
like hooking up with a friend or a bad
lapse of judgment mistake yeah I don't
call it a one-night stand it's just I
look at those eyes because I think then
that both of us I've never had one-night
stands I see you haven't had one either
wait why did I have one because your
one-night stand you didn't just hook up
with a stranger all right no no what I'm
saying is what I'm saying is I had a
one-night stand with me then I tried to
build I tried to yes i undid the magic
but she wasn't a stranger you kind of
knew each I didn't know her at all and I
just met her that night she came to my
improv show I had just she was like in
the audience I thought it was an
improviser this whole time I know I
never would [ __ ] improviser okay yeah
because I could have been in a power
position where I could have gotten her
on an improv team see a herald team I
didn't want to have that kind of
response wait wait were you on a Harold
T booth
I was actually wait you were yeah I was
on the first tale team's ever for the
Westside collector what's that what's
that comedy okay
the first Harold its first group of hell
yeah no I don't know a lot of people
that run around like that what never
never no I was agreeing with because
when you say Harold team and improv role
that you usually they're talking about
UCB here it's not talk about UCB myzel
shut the foot but it's a student
baseball right now it's [ __ ] the
Improv joke ever
so yeah I'm sorry
explain it but now she did doesn't
matter it was a shitty theater that's
all
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]